Sobre la mesa hay 76 objetos
para el placer y el dolor.
Algunos de los objetos son
un vaso de agua, un abrigo, un zapato, una rosa.
Pero también un cuchillo, una hoja de afeitar, un martillo
y una pistola con una bala.
Hay instrucciones que dicen,
"Soy un objeto.
Todo lo de la mesa puede utilizarse en mí.
Asumo toda la responsabilidad, incluso si me matan.
Y tienen seis horas".
El inicio de esta actuación fue fácil.
La gente me daba el vaso con agua para beber,
Me daba la rosa.
Pero poco después,
había un hombre que tomó las tijeras y me cortó la ropa,
y luego arrancaron las espinas de la rosa y me las pegaron en el estómago.
Alguien tomó la hoja de afeitar me cortó el cuello y bebió mi sangre
y todavía tengo la cicatriz.
Las mujeres decían a los hombres qué hacer.
Y los hombres no me violaron porque era solo una inauguración normal,
y era todo público,
y estaban con sus esposas.
Me cargaron y me pusieron sobre la mesa,
y me pusieron el cuchillo entre las piernas.
Y alguien tomó la pistola y la bala y me la puso en la sien.
Y otra persona tomó la pistola y comenzó una pelea.
Y después cumplirse las seis horas,
yo...
comencé a caminar hacia el público.
Estaba hecha un desastre.
Medio desnuda, llena de sangre y las lágrimas me corrían por la cara.
Y todo el mundo se escapó, simplemente huyeron.
No podían afrontarme como un ser humano normal.
Y entonces --
lo que pasó
al irme al hotel, ya eran las dos de la mañana.
Y...
me miré en el espejo,
y tenía un pedazo de pelo gris.
Bien --
por favor, sáquense las vendas de los ojos.
Bienvenidos al mundo del arte efímero.
En primer lugar, explicaré qué es el arte efímero.
Muchos artistas dan muchas explicaciones diferentes,
pero mi explicación del arte efímero es muy simple.
El arte efímero es una construcción mental y física
que el artista hace en un momento determinado
en un espacio en frente de una audiencia
para que suceda el diálogo vital.
El público y el artista componen juntos la pieza.
Y la diferencia entre el arte efímero y el teatro es enorme.
En el teatro, el cuchillo no es un cuchillo
y la sangre es solo salsa de tomate.
En el arte efímero, la sangre es el material,
y la hoja de afeitar o el cuchillo es la herramienta.
Todo es cuestión de estar allí en el tiempo real,
y el arte efímero no se puede ensayar,
porque no se puede hacer muchas de estas cosas dos veces, una vez.
Lo cual es muy importante en el arte efímero.
Uds. saben, los humanos siempre tenemos miedo de cosas muy simples.
Tenemos miedo al sufrimiento, tenemos miedo al dolor,
tenemos miedo a la muerte.
Así que lo que hago
es poner este tipo de temores en escena frente a la audiencia.
Estoy usando su energía,
y con esta energía puedo llevar a mi cuerpo al límite.
Y luego me libero de estos temores.
Y yo soy su espejo.
Si puedo hacer esto sola, Uds. puede hacerlo por Uds. mismos.
Después de Belgrado, donde nací,
fui a Ámsterdam.
Y he estado haciendo actuaciones
en los últimos 40 años.
Y ahí me encontré con Ulay,
y él era de la persona que realmente me enamoré.
Y durante 12 años, hemos hecho actuaciones juntos.
Y el cuchillo, las pistolas y las balas,
las puedo cambiar por amor y confianza.
Para hacer este tipo de trabajo se debe confiar en la persona por completo
porque esta flecha apunta a mi corazón.
Por lo tanto, el corazón late y la adrenalina corre, etc.,
es una cuestión de confianza, de una total confianza a otro ser humano.
Nuestra relación era de 12 años,
y trabajamos en muchos temas, tanto la energía masculina, como femenina.
Y como cada relación llega a su fin, la nuestra también.
No queríamos hacer llamadas de teléfono como hacen las personas normales
y decir: Esto se acabó".
Caminamos por la Gran Muralla de China para despedirnos.
Yo empecé en el Mar Amarillo, y él desde el desierto de Gobi.
Cada uno caminamos durante tres meses,
2500 km.
Había montañas, fue difícil.
Había subidas, había ruinas.
Se trataba de ir a través de las 12 provincias de China,
esto fue antes de que China se abriera en 1987.
Y logramos reunirnos en el centro
para decirnos adiós.
Y entonces nuestra relación se detuvo.
Y a partir de ahí yo cambié por completo la forma ver al público.
Y una pieza muy importante que llevé a cabo en aquellos días
fue "Balkan Baroque".
Y era la época de las guerras de los Balcanes,
y quería crear una imagen muy fuerte y carismática,
algo que pudiera servir para cualquier guerra en cualquier momento,
la guerra de los Balcanes finalizó, pero siempre hay guerra en alguna parte.
Así que aquí estoy lavando
2500 huesos de vaca llenos de sangre, grandes y muertos.
No se puede lavar la sangre, nunca se logra lavar la vergüenza de las guerras.
Así estoy lavando esto 6 horas, 6 días, y de las guerras vienen estos huesos,
y se respira un olor insoportable.
Pero entonces algo se queda en la memoria.
Quiero mostrarles qué fue lo que realmente cambió mi vida,
y fue la actuación en el MoMa que hice hace poco.
"En esta actuación", le dije al curador,
"me voy a sentar en la silla,
y habrá una silla vacía en la parte delantera,
y cualquiera del público puede venir y sentarse el tiempo que quiera".
El comisario me dijo:
"Eso es ridículo, ya sabes, esto es Nueva York,
esta silla permanecerá vacía,
nadie tiene tiempo para sentarse delante de ti".
(Risas)
Pero estuve sentada durante tres meses.
Y me sentaba todos los días, 8 horas,
desde que abría el museo,
y los viernes 10 horas, porque el museo abre 10 horas,
y nunca me movía.
Y quité la mesa y todavía estoy sentada,
y esto lo cambió todo.
En esta actuación, tal vez 10 o 15 años atrás,
quizá no habría pasado nada.
Pero la necesidad de la gente de experimentar algo diferente,
el público no era más el grupo.
La relación era de uno a uno.
Yo veía a esta gente, que venía y se sentaba frente a mí,
pero tenían que esperar horas y horas y horas
hasta tocarles el turno
y, finalmente, se sentaban.
¿Y qué pasó?
Ellos son observados por las otras personas,
ellos son fotografiados, ellos están siendo filmados,
están siendo observados por mí
y no tienen adonde escapar, excepto a sí mismos.
Y eso marca la diferencia.
Había tanto dolor y soledad,
hay tanto cosas increíbles al mirar en los ojos de otra persona,
porque en la mirada de un extraño,
que ni siquiera dices una palabra, todo sucede.
Y comprendí cuando me levanté de la silla después de tres meses,
que no soy la misma de antes.
Y entendí que tengo una misión muy grande,
de que tengo que comunicar esta experiencia
a todos.
Y es así como nació la idea
de tener un instituto de artes escénicas inmateriales.
Porque al pensar en la inmaterialidad,
el arte escénico es el arte basado en el tiempo.
No es como una pintura.
Uno tiene la pintura en la pared, al día siguiente sigue ahí.
Con el arte efímero, si se quiere ver, es suficiente con la memoria,
o la historia de alguien que se lo cuente.
Pero en realidad se pierde el todo.
Así que hay que estar allí.
Y mi opinión, si se habla de arte inmaterial,
la música es lo más; el arte absolutamente más elevado de todos,
porque es la más inmaterial.
Y después de esto es el arte escénico, y luego todo lo demás.
Esa es mi manera subjetiva.
Este instituto se abrirá en Hudson, al norte de Nueva York,
y estamos intentando construir con Rem Koolhaas, una idea.
Y es muy simple.
Si deseas obtener experiencia, me tienes que dar tu tiempo.
Uno ha de firmar el contrato antes de entrar en el edificio,
de que va a pasar allí un total de seis horas,
uno debe darme su palabra de honor.
Es algo tan pasado de moda,
pero si uno no respeta su propia palabra de honor y sale antes,
ese no es mi problema.
Pero la experiencia es de seis horas.
Y a continuación, tras terminar, se obtiene un certificado de logro,
que al llegar a casa se puede enmarcar si se desea.
(Risas)
Esta es la sala de orientación.
El público entra y lo primero que debe hacer es ponerse una bata de laboratorio.
Es importante
para pasar de ser un simple espectador a un experimentador.
Y luego se va a las taquillas
para depositar reloj, iPhone, iPod, PC,
y todo lo digital o electrónico.
Y uno va a tener tiempo libre para sí mismo por primera vez.
Aunque que no hay nada de malo con la tecnología,
nuestro enfoque de la tecnología es erróneo.
Perdemos el tiempo que tenemos para nosotros mismos.
Este es un instituto que, en realidad, va a devolver este momento.
Entonces, ¿qué hace uno aquí?
En primer lugar, hay que caminar lento, hay que disminuir la velocidad.
Se vuelve a la simplicidad.
Después de caminar lento, uno aprende a beber agua.
Muy simple, beber agua potable durante una media hora.
Después de esto, uno va a la cámara magnética,
donde uno crea corrientes magnéticas en el cuerpo.
Luego, tras esto, uno va a la cámara de cristal.
Después de cámara de cristal, a la cámara del ojo observador,
después de la cámara del ojo observador, uno va a una cámara donde uno se acuesta.
Así son las tres posiciones básicas del cuerpo humano,
sentado, de pie y acostado.
Y caminar lento.
Y hay una cámara de sonido.
Y a continuación, tras haber visto todo esto,
y haberse preparado mentalmente y físicamente,
entonces uno está listo para ver algo con larga duración,
al igual que en el arte inmaterial.
Puede ser música, ópera o una obra de teatro,
Puede ser una película, un video de baile.
Uno va a las sillas de larga duración porque ahora uno ya está cómodo.
En las sillas de larga duración,
uno es transportado al gran lugar donde se va a ver la obra.
Y si uno se queda dormido,
lo cual es muy posible por ser un largo día,
uno será llevado a la zona de aparcamiento.
(Risas)
Y, ¿saben?, dormir es muy importante.
Durmiendo, uno todavía percibe el arte.
En el estacionamiento uno permanece durante un cierto periodo de tiempo,
y luego después de esto, uno vuelve,
uno ve más cosas que le gusta ver
o vuelve a casa con su certificado.
Este instituto en este momento es virtual.
En este momento, estoy haciendo el instituto en Brasil,
luego habrá uno en Australia,
a continuación, en Canadá y en todas partes.
Y esto es para experimentar un método simple,
cómo volver a la sencillez en la propia vida.
Contar arroz es otra de las cosas.
(Risas)
Si se cuenta arroz, se puede ganar la vida, también.
¿Cómo contar arroz durante seis horas?
Es increíblemente importante.
Uno pasa por todo, desde aburrirse, estar enojado,
estar completamente frustrado, a no terminar de contar la cantidad de arroz.
Y luego se obtiene una paz increíble
cuando se termina un trabajo satisfactorio.
O contar arena en el desierto.
O tener una situación aislada de sonido,
con auriculares que no dejan oír nada.
Y uno está allí sin sonido,
con personas experimentando silencio, completo silencio.
Siempre hacemos cosas que nos gustan en la vida.
Y es por esto que uno no cambia.
Uno hace cosas en la vida,
y simplemente no pasa nada, si siempre se hacen las cosas de igual manera.
Pero mi método es hacer las cosas que me dan miedo, las cosas que temo,
las cosas que no conozco,
para ir al territorio que nadie fue.
Y luego también para incluir el fracaso.
Creo que el fracaso es importante
porque si uno experimenta, puede fallar.
Si uno no entra en esa zona y no falla,
en realidad uno se repite una y otra vez.
Y creo que los humanos, en este momento, necesitan un cambio,
y el único cambio que se debe hacer es un cambio a nivel personal.
Uno tiene que hacer su propio cambio.
Debido a que la única manera de cambiar la conciencia
y cambiar el mundo que nos rodea,
es empezar con uno mismo.
Es fácil criticar lo diferente,
las cosas en el mundo y que no son correctas,
como que los gobiernos son corruptos y que hay hambre en el mundo
y guerras y muertes.
Pero ¿qué hacemos a nivel personal?
¿Cuál es nuestra contribución a todo esto?
¿Se pueden girar al vecino de al lado que no conocen
y mirarle a los ojos durante dos minutos completos ahora?
(Charla)
Les pido solo dos minutos de su tiempo, eso es muy poco.
Respiren lento, no intenten parpadear, no sean conscientes de sí mismos.
Estén relajados.
Y solo miren a un completo extraño a los ojos, en sus ojos.
(Silencio)
Gracias por confiar en mí.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Gracias.
Muchas gracias.